[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
saw this where
barry sanders tweeted this morning he
was excited to talk to his quote
movie star friend the hall of famer
barry sanders joining us on the program
so you've seen my body of work barry
absolutely who hasn't how would you rate
my
my acting ability i'll see that come on
come
on
now why would you want to put me on the
spot like that man what would you want
to put me on the spot
um you know but because i would say
i would say no hey we're on your show
how about two thumbs up well how many
movies have you been in barry
oh ouch ouch okay um
not not very many not very i think one
what was the movie i think i think one
it was called
um touch back i believe
[Laughter]
did you play yourself in touch back
um i played basically i was on the
sideline
acting as a uh a uh
a coach oh you know like an assistant
coach on the sidelines what is this
kurt russell kurt russell there you go
there you go so you've seen it
you've seen it no i haven't seen my work
no you've seen my work
[Laughter]
what do you think when you see your old
game film
when you're watching highlights and you
come on
oh i mean it just you know what it just
kind of brings back memories of being
young and and being able to do that kind
of cool stuff
on the field and and living out my dream
um and really almost those kind of
butterflies
you know of actually playing in the game
and that that sort of excitement you get
um while you're actually going through
it in the middle of it so it's pretty
cool
can you teach your style of running
that's a good question i think i think
i think to some to some yes you can
teach it
to others maybe not but i think i think
who can i teach them too how many guys
had your ability to
cut i don't know how fast you were i
just know
you had that ability to cut
absolutely no i i think but i think to
the right individuals i think you can
teach it but how many guys i mean
i don't know i mean dan um i i watched
the game as a kid and i was imitating
so many guys like joe washington and
greg pruitt and tony dorsett and oj
and marcus allen and guys like that um
so i can't i can't
sit up here like i authored any any of
it
yeah but barry you know what you're
perfect though your style was you had to
run for your life
behind that lion's offensive line like
that was your style
no hey look i you know i think um
for me yeah absolutely it was my style
that's the way i'd always run i i
trust me um as a kid that's the way i
ran um
you know even when i didn't have the
lions offensive line you know so
but that's just the way i ran take me
back to when you played your last game
and i got a call from your agent peter
shafer and he said
hey barry's going to take a flight to
london
right right right okay did you know
prior to the game
that that was your last game and that
you were going to take a flight to
london
as you ended your nfl career well no at
the time i retired i didn't know i was
going to take a flight to london because
the flight to london happened in july or
something like that on the eva training
camp
um and the last game would have been
that december i guess
of 98 i would think
and so um and so but i knew that season
that that was pretty much it um i knew
uh
you know i just i just knew that you
know what i i played
ten great years and had had a great run
um didn't see uh didn't really see a
reason to
you know continue um in the game i knew
that that drive
and you know that that kind of thing you
that that
that um pilot light you know that that's
always lit
that drives you that um you know
uh that drives that that fire within i
just knew that that was gone at
year 10 and it was just time to move on
i mean it's something it's something
that i mean i guess unless you
unless you've had that experience of
where where you know you have to make a
change in life like that maybe it
doesn't
sound very clear but i just knew that
and understood it yes it's time it's
time to move on
was there any part of you who didn't
want to break walter payton's
rushing record
um i don't know i mean that's a
that's a tough question to answer
because being a lifelong fan of
nfl and walter payton and running backs
i understood what that meant
um but i just knew that uh for me
you know the game had just run its
course and i you know
i didn't get it in the time that i
played um you know
i got close enough and it's you know
it's always an
honor to be mentioned with walter um you
know so
so um you know so yeah that that's kind
of hard
but i also wonder you know the lions
just said to matthew stafford hey
we're gonna let you like you pick where
you want to go or we're gonna
try to help you go someplace i was
wondering if you were playing now with
the lions
and they weren't winning and they had
that
you know maybe they would look at the
same way and go hey you want to go to
the raiders we're going to send you to
the raiders or
your favorite team i think back then do
you think that's what the lions were
doing with matthew stafford is basically
saying hey
we're not going anywhere here's our
thank you to you we're going to
send you to the la rams yeah i mean
there
apparently uh seemed to be some some of
that
um i think it's a different it's a
different league now um
i think uh and you know he's meant so
much to
the franchise um he's carried us for
many many years and
and um you know so so yeah i mean what
you know whatever that conversation was
the two
sort of uh came to an agreement that
that was the best thing for both parties
um you know i don't i don't know exactly
you know the details of the conversation
um but um but what a blockbuster trait
man
i mean wow um you know and and uh
and so hey look hopefully it works out
well for both
um you know we're getting uh we're
getting a young man who's played a lot
of
a lot of um and some very big games in a
short career
um you know and and we'll see what
happens and you're okay with the trade
for the
if you're being aligned i think we dan i
think i think we got a lot for it okay
i think we got a lot i think we got a
lot for it i think uh
wow i mean you know you look at the
picks and and things like that
um yeah i think i think uh we came out
pretty good
uh to this point i think we can say that
yeah we should feel pretty good about it
he's barry sanders a hall of famer
joining us we'll get to what he's
promoting here in a moment
did you have any part in the dan
campbell hire his head coach
i wouldn't say i played a major role in
it but i was kind of involved
um in just the conversation with chris
billman and
and uh so forth um um
you know so i knew that he was going to
talk to coach campbell and some others
um he's kind of goofy barry
well you know i i guess uh i guess uh
you know he's a great coach um a great
great coaching prospect
he's been around the game i i you know i
kind of enjoyed the the um press
conference
you know it was kind of entertaining um
you know and so you got you got to come
in and
entertain the fans a little bit right
you know well you would hope the team
would entertain them barry but if
if the team doesn't do well then dan
should be uh entertaining in those press
conferences
well i mean you got to start off you got
to start off some way and i think he
left a good impression
um you know and and um
and so you know i i i enjoyed it
and got a few chuckles out of the press
conference and
and now you need a few guys who's going
to bite on some ankles and knees and
you would not have been his kind of
player barrack you're not biting any
ankles or kneecaps
well i don't know i i can't say as a
defensive player if i was if i were on
defense
i you know i don't know i you know
personalities change a little bit here
and there
would you be a safety or corner i become
a different animal dan
a different animal could you have been
deion sanders no i couldn't i don't want
to go that far
but no i love playing defense and you
know
of course in my generation most of us
growing up playing the game we played
on both sides of the ball you know so i
absolutely love playing defense and i
played
varsity defense in high school before i
played offense
um you know and so uh i i thought i was
a pretty decent cornerback i mean i
i'd have to go back and look at the got
the tape you know
but in my mind i thought i thought i was
a pretty decent point
uh he's barry sanders the hall of famer
and uh
joining us on behalf of rocket mortgage
the super bowl squares sweepstakes there
do you want to
let the audience know what they can win
how they can be involved i want to hear
you as the salespers
give me the uh give me the sales pitch
here barry no absolutely
dan we're just trying to give fans
watching the big game a chance to win a
lot of cash
you know and so um the way it works is
you know every score change during the
game touchdowns field goals extra points
um fans will have a chance to win fifty
thousand dollars
um two fans two lucky fans will win half
a million dollars
um so it's free to play so just go to
rocketmortgagesquares.com
learn more about it um it's going to be
a terrific game you got two quarterbacks
that
that can set the scoreboard on fire
that'll that'll bode well for squares
players
um and we hope just you know that
rocketmore gives you a and square play
square players
you know win a lot of cash when's the
last time you bet on a sporting event
oh i don't know what middle school maybe
[Laughter]
you were never interested in uh after
you got out of uh football you didn't
gamble at all didn't bet on anything no
no nothing no i i never did i mean it
was it was probably
last time i bailed maybe in the raiders
raiders washington super bowl what was
that 84
83 or something like that that was when
marcus had his run
absolutely oh yeah absolutely absolutely
yes
so uh but yeah i've never been a big
gambler in that way if if i said you
were gm you could start your
team with any running back besides you
oh
who are you going to start with besides
me
any running back who's ever played um
wow i would probably i would probably go
with
jim brown i would go with jim brown
i know your dad loved jim brown but i
don't know how jim would do in today's
game would jim brown be
derek henry i think he'd be derek henry
honestly
that's that's kind of what i was
thinking i can't imagine tackling derek
henry barry
oh i know i know that's why i'm i'm glad
i'm glad you know i
i um i stopped playing cornerback you
know move the running backs
you know trying to tackle guys no but
derek i think he's the closest thing to
jim brown you look at what he's done the
last couple years
phenomenal year this year um going over
2 000 yards
i wouldn't be surprised to see him do it
again um it'd be kind of cool to see
to see the first guy able to do it twice
um you know i've said this before i
think outside of my homes and maybe
rogers he's probably been the most
dominant player in the game
um you know so so yeah he's been he's
been phenomenal but
that's but yeah i i guess i'd go with i
would go with jim because i think he
i think he probably dominated the game
he dominated the game
like no other running back did or has
when he played
and so um got to give the nod to mr
brown
my dad taught me well oh i remember that
gosh he used to remind you
all the time about you're no jim brown
hey look i mean and to me that's that's
still a compliment especially coming
from my dad wasn't really a com
it was a backhanded compliment yeah
going from my dad you know that's like
one of the nicest things you've ever
said to me
why do you think he was so tough on you
you know i don't know that he was tough
as much as just in his mind
he would he would say he was just
preparing me and
and just honest you know that's that's
how he felt i mean
um but the funny thing about the jim
brown thing is that
really all my life um long before i was
like high school or college or any kind
of a
any you know heisman trophy any of that
he just loved talking about jim brown
you know just because you know i was
interested in certain running backs when
i was growing up
and he would that would give him you
know um the motivation uh to just
start talking about jim brown how great
he was and how you know
none of the current running backs could
stand up to jim brown you know so
so he was just so i don't i don't even
know if he was about you know the fact
that i ended up being a running back
just
uh other than or just he loved jim brown
and that was his guy
um you know so that's kind of how that
was did you ever get hit where it really
hurt
like i don't remember you taking on
tacklers the way
other running you avoided it but did you
ever get hit like
get your bell wrong or get really banged
up one time
by a defender oh yeah absolutely
absolutely i think um my first uh my
first start
i remember was in the meadowlands and i
got the wind knocked out of me
and uh i don't remember even remember
who it was
um but but even you know so that's
that's probably the
one time where where i probably had to
come out of the game but
i think because of adrenaline and you
know because you're
you're in the heat of the moment it
happens often but you don't notice it
at least for me anyways that was my
personal experience
it happened um but no i mean yeah but it
certainly happened after that but that's
the one that i
i remember probably the most well it's
good to see you
looks like you could probably uh give me
a couple of carries in the game
oh i'd love to man i'd love to know it's
great it's great being here man
thanks for having me barry sanders is
coming back
i think you want to help jared goff are
you coming back for the lions
is that what you're announcing you want
to play again barry
um you mean on the field yeah running
back yeah
i i hadn't heard that rumor but uh oh oh
i'm going to check into that i'm about
to check into that i have to check into
that
are you saying you're open to it barry
i doubt it i doubt it
uh it's great to uh great to connect
with you again i hope you're doing well
probably playing a lot of golf not doing
anything else right
playing a little golf um you know just
taking it easy
i mean it's coveted man so what you know
how much can you do but
just taking it easy trying to stay safe
um and
pre appreciate your time man and good
luck to all the squares player out there
go to rocketmortgagesquares.com
find out more about it thank you buddy
thank you barry all right dan appreciate
it man that's barry sanders hall of
famer
mvp a 1997 four-time nfl rushing leader
with the lions